the final stretch before election day
and both president trump
and joe biden are spending time on the
campaign trail until the very last
moment
our washington correspondent alexandra
limon joining us now live in wilmington
delaware and
alex tell us how the democratic nominee
joe biden
spent his day and what the strategy is
for him on this final day before
election day
hey good evening well here in wilmington
delaware is where joe biden is expected
to make his election night speech
tomorrow night but today he did spend
the entire day on the campaign trail
starting off with a rally
in ohio and then he moved on to have
actually multiple
events in the state of pennsylvania and
it wasn't just joe biden it was his
running mate kamala harris also his wife
dr jill biden and other members of the
biden team
that just fanned out across the entire
state of pennsylvania
there's a couple of reasons for that
strategy wise number one they want to
get the message out to every single
voter
that their vote absolutely matters and
if they didn't vote early
they should get to the polls and try to
vote in in a safe way tomorrow
but number two pennsylvania is very much
up for grabs for either candidate
president trump or joe biden and there
are 20 electoral votes at stake
and president trump won by a very very
thin margin
in 2016 not just in pennsylvania but
michigan wisconsin
and so that's why biden is focusing on
the midwest
and also on pennsylvania and as you
mentioned pennsylvania and michigan both
key battleground states in the race for
president
but there are also states that we may
not know the results of on election
night
can you walk our viewers through why
yeah definitely you know every single
state has their own election laws and
other states like florida for example
that are also up for grabs very tight
race there
they can begin to count those mail-in
and absentee ballots
weeks ahead of time that is not the case
in pennsylvania or
in michigan those states cannot begin
counting until
election day and there are just
thousands of ballots that have been
pouring in
by mail because of the pandemic so the
election officials in those states say
it could take several days
perhaps as long as friday to get their
ballots counted and their results
finalized but i should mention this is
completely normal we see things like
this happen
every single election in one state or
another it happened in 2016.
they're just asking for some patience
while they get those ballots counted
we all probably can use a little
patience these days thank you so much
alexandra limon joining us tonight
from delaware we do appreciate your time
and thank you